El controvertido y extravagante
presidente de El Salvador,
Nayib Bukele ha arrasado en las
últimas elecciones salvadoreñas.
El presidente milenial, como le
conocen algunos, el caudillo milenial,
como le conocen otros, revalida otros 5
años al frente del país Centroamericano.
¿Su gran activo? Una reducción drástica e
incontestable de los crímenes violentos,
en especial, de los asesinatos. Un hito que
ha hecho de este país el barrio
más seguro de toda Latinoamérica.
El Salvador ha pasado de ser un país en el que
prácticamente no se podía salir tranquilo a la
calle a convertirse, posiblemente, en uno
de los más seguros de toda América Latina.
Se ha pasado de una tasa de 106,3 homicidios
violentos por cada 100.000 habitantes en 2015,
una tasa de homicidios que hacía que para muchos
fuese más seguro jugar a la ruleta rusa que salir
a comprar pan, a un impresionante 2,4 en 2023.
Casi la mitad que Argentina, la misma que cifra
que Lituania e inferior a la de otros países
europeos como Letonia o Andorra. Es decir,
Si se lo contaras a un salvadoreño hace apenas
cinco años seguramente se reiría tanto en tu cara
que seguramente necesitaría un inhalador para
poder coger óxigeno entre una carcajada y otra,
pero ahora esas son las cifras de las
que Bukele puede presumir y presume.
De hecho, toda su campaña electoral ha
estado centrada en sacar pecho de los
formidables resultados que ha tenido
su política de mano dura contra los
delincuentes y el desmantelamiento de las
estructuras a pie de calle de las Maras.
Para muchos esto es realmente lo que ha marcado
la diferencia. Muchos salvadoreños se sienten hoy
más libres que nunca, tan solo por el hecho
de poder salir a la calle con tranquilidad.
Por ejemplo, si a finales de 2019 Wel 70,4% de los
salvadoreños decía que la delincuencia era su gran
problema, ahora, hoy cuatro años después,
esa cifra se ha desplomado hasta el 4,3%.
Claro que no ha sido algo que haya
salido gratis. Esta guerra contra
el crimen no ha sido ni mucho menos
como jugar a la policía y ladrones en
el patio del recreo. Ha tenido un coste
muy alto, y no solo hablamos de dinero.
Y es que veréis, el gobierno salvadoreño
opera contra las bandas criminales
mediante estados de excepción que
le otorgan un poder sin precedentes.
Incluido poderes para detener a diestro
y siniestro a quien se ponga por delante,
en muchos casos sin apenas pruebas
o, simplemente, por motivos como
el aspecto físico de la persona. En otras
palabras: si tienes cara de malo, a la trena.
Por supuesto, esto tiene ventajas,
al dirigir las acciones en zonas muy
focalizadas se consigue detener a muchas
personas en un pispas, desmantelando las
estructuras de los grupos criminales a pie
de calle. Sin embargo, y este es el problema,
en torno al 10% de todas las personas que se
detienen en El Salvador son en realidad inocentes.
Ojo, esto no lo decimos nosotros, sino que
el gobierno lo asume con toda naturalidad.
(El Salvador libera a más
de 7.000 inocentes de sus cárceles - DW)
("A la fecha, son un poco más de 7.000 los
que han sido liberados de estos más de 72.000
(capturados). Quiere decir que el sistema de
Justicia está funcionando". - Gustavo Villatoro,
ministro de Justicia y Seguridad de El Salvador.)
Y ojo, que no se trata solo de detenciones.
Muchos de los juicios contra las maras han
sido colectivos, se ha condenado de facto
a un montón de acusados de golpe con muy
pocas pruebas. La mayoría seguro culpable…
Pero, claro, el problema es que hay excepciones.
También es importante destacar, como
seguramente recordaréis los que estáis
suscritos a nuestro Patreon porque os lo
contamos en nuestro boletín exclusivo,
que Bukele ha renovado su mandato bajo
serias dudas de inconstitucionalidad.
(Nayib Bukele, el “dictador más cool del mundo”,
reivindica reelección presidencial en El Salvador
Después de que su partido obtuviera la victoria
en las elecciones legislativas de 2021,
el congreso recién elegido purgó el tribunal
constitucional y reemplazó a los jueces por
leales. Posteriormente, los nuevos magistrados
dictaminaron que Bukele podía postularse para un
segundo mandato a pesar de la prohibición
constitucional de la reelección. - Time)
Digamos que después de esta maniobra digna de un
episodio de "House of Cards", consiguió saltarse
la prohibición constitucional y
asegurarse un segundo mandato,
Sin embargo, queridos, amigos, amigas, la
intención de este vídeo no es cargar contra
Nayib Bukele ni mucho menos, sino contaros
las claves de su primera presidencia más
allá del controvertido y polémico tema de los
métodos utilizados contra la delincuencia.
Vamos a responder a varias preguntas clave. Por
ejemplo, ¿qué ha supuesto Bukele para El Salvador
hasta ahora? ¿Qué hay más allá de la cortina
de “la seguridad”? ¿Qué se puede esperar de él
de cara a esta próxima legislatura? ¿Tiene un
proyecto de país aparte de reducir el crimen?
Pues bien, todo esto y más en
este vídeo así que, ¡atentos!
T1(HECHOS, NO PALABRAS)
La vida de muchos salvadoreños, quizás de
la inmensa mayoría, ha mejorado mucho con la
reducción del crimen. Eso es incontestable.
Pero, ¿qué hay más allá de esta cuestión?
Sí, lo sé, la seguridad es
asunto absolutamente clave,
pero, ¿qué ha pasado, por ejemplo, con
la economía durante los últimos años?
Pues bien, si Bukele se centra tanto en
hablar de la reducción de los homicidios
violentos y habla tan poco de otros
temas… Es precisamente porque en el
resto de materias por ahora no tiene
demasiado de lo que sentirse orgulloso.
La realidad es que El Salvador
no está hoy mejor económicamente
que en 2019 cuando Bukele se hizo con el poder.
Y si, lógicamente, la pandemia de la
COVID-19 justifica una parte importante
de este fracaso… Por eso, esta será una de las
cuestiones claves de esta nueva legislatura.
Y, ojo, porque aquí las cosas no pintan tan bien.
Por ejemplo, desde el principio del mandato de
Bukele la deuda pública se ha disparado.
El actual presidente salvadoreño recibió
una deuda de poco más de 12.700 millones de
dólares y ahora está se ha incrementado más de
un 40% hasta rondar los 18 mil millones. Y eso
sin contar la deuda del sistema de pensiones.
Por otra parte, Bukele confió demasiado en el
Bitcoin para financiar programas sociales y gastos
corrientes a través de programas de compra
de esta criptomoneda por parte del Estado.
Y pese a todo, la adopción del Bitcoin hoy por
hoy no ha cuajado entre la sociedad salvadoreña.
A finales de 2022, poco después de un año de
anunciarlo a bombo y platillo, solo el 24% de la
población había usado Bitcoin para comprar o hacer
pagos. Y en 2023 los datos fueron aún peores.
Y eso no es todo. Los datos nos dicen que
el 66% de los salvadoreños ha considerado
un fracaso su aprobación como moneda
de curso oficial y el 77% considera
que el gobierno debería parar de gastar
dinero público en esta criptodivisa.
Y a ver, inicialmente, la idea podría
tener sentido, puesto que con esto el
gobierno quería entre otras cosas, reducir el
altísimo porcentaje de población no bancarizada
en el país, y facilitar que los migrantes
enviasen remesas en Bitcoin a El Salvador.
Digamos que el problema es que a
día de hoy apenas un 40% de los
salvadoreños tienen y usan con
regularidad una cuenta bancaria.
Pero pese a ello, solo el 3% de los salvadoreños
consideran que la “estrategia cripto” del
presidente ha mejorado su situación económica,
y para la mayoría las cosas siguen igual.
Y no solo eso. Es que, tras años encadenando
reducciones importantes en las tasas de pobreza y
pobreza extrema, estas apenas han cambiado durante
el primer gobierno de Bukele. Es decir, que las
políticas de este gobierno han sido hasta ahora
incapaces de generar un marco de prosperidad.
Luego, otro gran fracaso de Bukele
fueron los llamados “Bonos Volcán”,
un proyecto que consistía en
emitir deuda soberana para
refinanciar su deuda externa y construir
la utópica y cosmopolítica Bitcoin City,
además de una macro-planta para minar bitcoins
con la energía térmica del volcán Conchagua.
Bukele quería emitir a partir
de marzo de 2022 bonos de deuda
pública a 10 años a un interés del
6,5 % para recaudar 1.000 millones
de dólares con los que poder cumplir
ese objetivo. Al final no lo consiguió.
Por ahora el proyecto, una de las grandes
apuestas anunciadas por este gobierno, ha sido
sustituido por una planta de energía renovable de
capital privado que ya ha comenzado a funcionar.
Claro que, amigos,… el bitcoin y la
economía no son las únicas sombras
que muchos denuncian sobre este gobierno
y particularmente sobre este presidente.
Y es que veréis, según el departamento
de Justicia de Estados Unidos,
Bukele realizó acuerdos secretos
al principio de su mandato con la
pandilla MS-13 para que esta detuviera
los actos violentos en las calles.
Esos acuerdos incluían la liberación de un
miembro que tenía una orden de extradición a
Estados Unidos, acortar algunas penas y mejorar
las condiciones carcelarias de algunos presos.
También se ha acusado al gobierno de Nayib
Bukele de pactar con el Cártel de Jalisco
Nueva Generación, para atrapar a Élmer
Canales Rivera, líder de la mara MS-13,
a cambio de un millón de dólares para el
grupo criminal mexicano… Y probablemente
también la vista gorda de las autoridades
respecto a las actividades de este grupo.
Todo a cambio de ayudar a cumplir al Gobierno su
promesa electoral de reducir
los asesinatos en el país.
Sin embargo, el supuesto incumplimiento por
parte de las maras y la ola de violencia
desatada en 2022 condujo a Bukele
a implantar el estado de excepción.
Una situación de excepción que todavía hoy,
casi dos años después, sigue en vigor y que
parece ya más la norma que la excepción
en la forma de gestionar de este gobierno.
Eso sí, ahora las cosas pintan
muy diferentes para Bukele.
Y es que, veréis, una vez “solucionado el tema de
la seguridad” es muy probable que los salvadoreños
le exijan al presidente millennial en esta
nueva legislatura resultados económicos claros.
Por eso la pregunta clave es, ¿Qué podemos
esperar de Bukele a partir de 2024?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2(FUTURO DE INCERTIDUMBRE)
Vale, es innegable, Bukele ha
tenido durante estos años grandes
éxitos en materia de seguridad. No seremos
nosotros quienes neguemos esta realidad,
ni tampoco quienes no reconozcamos la gigantesca
importancia que esto tiene en un país que ha
sido durante años y años considerados como
uno de los más peligrosos de todo el mundo.
Algo que se ha traducido en un increíble
nivel de popularidad pública. Bukele es
probablemente el líder político más popular
de todo el mundo. Y el resultado electoral,
donde se ha hecho con el 85%
de los votos, así lo atestigua.
El problema para Bukele es sobre todo una
cuestión de expectativas. Su gran éxito
ya se está normalizando y digiriendo
por parte de la población salvadoreña,
que ha empezado a fijarse más en otros problemas.
En otras palabras, que lo que puede parecer
una buenísima noticia para El Salvador,
y desde luego lo es, que cada vez menos
gente se preocupe por la delincuencia,
podría terminar curiosamente siendo una malísima
noticia para Bukele. Cosas de la política.
Por tanto, la pregunta es, ¿qué planes
tiene ahora por delante este presidente?
Pues… Siento defraudaros, pero sobre los planes
fuera de la seguridad, se sabe entre poco y nada.
La campaña electoral en El Salvador
se ha enfocado casi exclusivamente en
lo ocurrido en los últimos cinco años, y
eso ha sido así tanto por parte de unos,
los oficialistas, como de otros, la oposición.
2:09 Demostremos al
2:11 mundo entero
de que los salvadoreños sí
2:13 apoyamos este proyecto, nuestro país
2:16 cambió eso nadie lo puede negar, pero
2:18 ahora nuestro trabajo este domingo es
2:20 garantizar que esos
cambios sean para siempre.
Sin embargo, como os acabamos de contar, El
Salvador tiene serios problemas económicos,
problemas que necesitan medidas urgentes.
C2(El Ejecutivo señaló que había logrado
recomprar deuda soberana por unos 565
millones de dólares. [...] En enero de 2023 el
país debía pagar unos 800 millones de dólares en
amortizaciones e intereses de su pasivo, y una
cifra similar en 2025. Esa es la deuda que el
presidente Bukele está recomprando para reducir
montos de pago - Forbes, 17 de febrero 2023)
En otras palabras, que la situación fiscal
salvadoreña está “atada de pies y manos”.
El país es, a día de hoy, el más endeudado de
toda Centroamérica y su economía apenas crece
a ritmos del 2%. Insuficiente para que
un país tan pobre pueda salir del hoyo.
Por este motivo, uno de los mayores retos
para Bukele de cara a su próximo gobierno
es conseguir suficiente credibilidad internacional
para el año 2027, cuando se van a producir enormes
vencimientos de deuda pública que, por supuesto,
El Salvador tendrá que ver como refinanciar.
Pero por ahora lo cierto es que Bukele no está
consiguiendo atraer demasiado
entusiasmo en el extranjero.
Sí, vale, ya lo se, para los
criptofans es como una especie
de icono, y la reducción del crimen ha
permitido aumentar bastante el turismo.
Sin embargo, cuando hablamos
de cosas más profundas,
los resultados son más bien malos. Fijaos:
Desde 2017 la inversión extranjera
directa se ha derrumbado en El Salvador
y esto es algo que los planes del actual
gobierno no han conseguido reconducir.
Todo lo contrario. El último
dato disponible, el de 2022,
nos muestra que la Inversión Extranjera
directa neta fue negativa. Es decir,
que llegaron al país menos capitales
de los que se fugaron del mismo.
Y, claro, esto en un contexto en el que casi
en10% de la población vive en la pobreza extrema,
y en el que el 42% de los niños son
pobres, es algo poco prometedor.
Pero por ahora, como os decimos, no hay
grandes proyectos económicos a largo plazo.
Por supuesto, cuando se gobierna
un país no solo se mira dentro de
casa. La agenda exterior suele
tener también bastante peso.
Y aquí, amigos, digamos que El Salvador
tiene una dicotomía bastante grande.
Y es que llegó al poder, Bukele no ha tenido
relaciones particularmente buenas con Washington.
De hecho, el propio Departamento de
Justicia de Estados Unidos mantiene
sanciones sobre algunos altos cargos muy próximos
al presidente bajo acusaciones de corrupción.
Luego, sus constantes encontronazos con la
Casa Blanca y el informe de los fiscales
estadounidenses asegurando que su gobierno
ha pactado con grupos criminales ha hecho
que Bukele lleve ya más de tres años con
una narrativa bastante antiamericana.
2:28 Durante décadas probamos todo lo que nos
2:31 dijeron que era lo mejor para nosotros,
2:34 nos pusieron a luchar una guerra civil
2:38 por una causa ajena a nuestra realidad,
2:40 porque llevaron el conflicto entre
2:42 occidente la Unión Soviética
a nuestra
2:44 tierra.)
El caso es que, en política internacional,
sus desencuentros con el Tío Sam les
han empujado a mirar hacia el otro
protagonista de la escena internacional.
Sí, por supuesto, hablamos de China.
Si en 2018 el predecesor de Bukele revirtió
el reconocimiento oficial a Taiwán,
el actual gobierno ha redoblado la apuesta.
Este gobierno ha intentado estrechar
mucho las relaciones con Xi Jinping,
que es lo que explica titulares como este:
N3 (Las millonarias obras financiadas por China en
El Salvador y qué papel juegan en la
reelección que busca Bukele - BBC)
N4 (El Salvador y China negociarán un acuerdo
de libre comercio que estará
listo "lo antes posible" - CNN)
Claro que esto podría cambiar
en 2024. ¿Qué por qué?
Pues, veréis, no es ningún secreto, el presidente
millennial y el no tan millenial Donald Trump se
llevan bastante bien, y no suelen ahorrar
elogios el uno para el otro. Pero claro,
Trump tiene también una cruzada contra china.
Así que si el expresidente logrará regresar
al Despacho Oval, Bukele podría encontrarse
de repente con el dilema de si mantener los
compromisos ya cerrados con China, o romper por lo
sano y alinearse con Washington. El tiempo dirá.
De todo lo demás, la verdad, no se sabe
mucho. El nuevo gobierno de Bukele va a ser,
grosso modo, un gran misterio. Nayib Bukele
ha vivido políticamente de un tema central,
la seguridad, pero veremos cuanto
logra mantener esa llama viva.
Queridos amigos, amigas, con este vídeo, aquí
en VisualPolitik os hemos querido contar las
principales claves que explican la incontestable
y brutal victoria de Bukele, los puntos flacos o
no tan bonitos del presidente salvadoreño
y los retos que tendrá ahora por delante.
Lo que termine pasando, pues solo Bukele lo
puede saber. Como siempre aquí estaremos muy
atentos para contaros todo lo que ocurra.
Desde toda la familia Visual os deseamos a
todos los que nos veis desde El Salvador
mucha suerte. Habéis conseguido un logro
enorme y habéis puesto a El Salvador en la
agenda internacional y en la agenda de miles
de turistas que quieren conocer vuestro
bello país. Ahora toca el siguiente paso.
Dicho esto:
¿Crees que la reelección de Bukele es una buena
noticia para El Salvador? ¿Piensas que logrará
resultados al abordar otros problemas
del país, más allá de la reducción de
la delincuencia? Y lo que es más importante,
¿crees que Bukele ha llegado para quedarse?
Pues bien, déjanos tus opiniones aquí debajo,
en los comentarios, y abramos el debate. Si te
ha gustado este vídeo dale like y suscríbete a
VisualPolitik para no perderte ninguna novedad.
Y ahora sí, ¡un saludo y hasta la próxima!